is just vlogbrothers hey everybody
um thank you so much for for joining us
um we are live now I think on the
vlogbrothers channel but I have to make
sure that it's working it is working all
right so we can see all your comments
um if we move over from private chat to
comments your comments just roll in good
morning so nice to see you sorry to be
one minute late people expect me to be
very punctual
um so I want to just first off I just
want to say that um because it's it
you're used to seeing me on this YouTube
channel you're not used to seeing our
other guests so I just want to briefly
introduce them and explain to that
explain to you why for me this is like
if my daughter was asked to interview
Olivia Rodrigo or Taylor Swift
um so
um we're joined by four of my absolute
Heroes four people I look up to a lot Dr
anime uh animesh Sinha uh Dr Carol
mitnick uh Nandita and uh fume's uh to
information for those who don't know are
TV survivors who join together with uh
Doctors Without Borders msf as it's
known
um to sue the Indian government to make
generic uh badakaline possible uh to
make it so that India would not honor uh
jnj's attempts to create a secondary
patent and extend the life of their
patent past its normal life they
succeeded that is the reason why generic
but aquoween was ready to be produced
the day the patent expired it is
incredible uh what they've what they've
accomplished not just with that project
but in their lives as a whole I'm so
excited uh to get to hear from them Dr
Sinha is a long time TB doctor
um in many countries around the world
and Dr Carol mitnick
um is my friend and and hero okay so
that's the that's a little bit of of
background I wanted to start with
Nandita because I don't know how my much
time she has she has a job
um
yeah
yeah well we're glad to have you here
while you're able to be here so I wonder
if you could just tell us a little bit
of your story of the challenges to find
out that you had tuberculosis and then
the extraordinary challenges you faced
through the treatment process
people have only met on social media and
it's very nice to see everyone here so I
uh I'm a two-time TV Survivor and I had
intestinal TB which is known as extra
pulmonary TB TB is generally known to be
you contracted in your lungs but that
was not in my case I've got it in my
intestine I had it for the first time in
2007 uh when I was a 17 year old just
about two months before I would turn an
adult I was diagnosed with the disease I
I was I I was starting my undergraduate
studies and right uh right in the middle
of that I get to know that okay wow I
have got this disease I had no idea
about this anywhere
um it was not a name that I was very
familiar with until I was told that I am
having it myself and then I I underwent
a treatment for close to 15 months after
that and I was cured completely um I was
my doctors told me that my treating
doctors told me that you're done and you
and you know you can go ahead with your
life and this disease is now a thing of
the past and you don't need to worry
about this disease anymore but then I
suffer I did my masters and then in 2013
I suffered a relapse uh what you call as
reinfection and the in and the disease
came back to the same organ intestine
and uh the medicines that I was put on
did not work on me very well I was told
that my disease has progressed to a very
severe stage and in the process of
getting treated I underwent six
surgeries in my abdomen and I was
hospitalized for close to 90 days I was
a 24 year old girl who was I was very
looking forward to the life ahead after
my after my post graduation Graduate
Studies but here I was this uh this
disease just through my life off the
cliff completely and after that in right
around November 2013 because of an
injection that was administered to me as
part of my treatment that was called as
canomycin I suffered a complete loss of
hearing so it would sound like I am
probably narrating a horror fiction but
but if I'll tell you the way I actually
lost my hearing it was like this that I
slept at around two o'clock in the in
the afternoon
um I I spoke to everyone around me my
family members everyone I I slept at 2PM
and I woke up at 2 15 and I couldn't
hear anything that's all so I was
actually able to hear everything before
that and then 15 minutes later I didn't
hear anything so I we initially thought
for a day I was living in sort of a
dinner aisle that okay maybe this is not
I mean where will one think about
hearing loss I mean these there's not
even a thing that anyone even thinks of
in the course of your regular treatment
that suddenly you will just lose your
hearing so we thought of other things
okay maybe something else it's just
something temporary but then I think a
day or two later we were informed that
this was because of a medicine and that
was I think that was I think one of the
most uh horrifying days of my life the
way that of my life the day I got to
know that it was a loss of hearing not
because of a bacteria which I was trying
to fight off but it was actually because
of a medicine that I that I lost the
hearing uh so that I think was was
something difficult to come to terms
with but then yeah so this was been my
journey with TB and today I guess we for
Mesa and we do it we just hope to ensure
that these kind of you know what do you
say horrifying or very difficult
experiences one need not confront with
the disease it should be just a cake
work for anyone who gets it that you
know okay I just take the medicine and
I'm cured no one needs to Grapple with
these kind of questions or existential
questions
both have Cochlear implants correct
but but many people who many people who
experience hearing loss from the
injectables are not able to afford
Cochlear implants because they're very
very expensive and so for many people uh
there is no I mean the the
there's the hearing the hearing loss is
is is permanent and it's um entire
um and there is no no no remedy for it
um and one of the reasons why
correct me if I'm wrong here Nandita but
one of the reasons you fought so hard
for access to badakaline is that
bedakylene can replace these injectables
and it's vastly more safe and it doesn't
cause hearing loss or the other
toxicities that are associated with
those injectable drugs is that right
citizen uh I I would like to add here
that no drug comes without its side
effects of course bed aquiline you have
to be careful about say cardiotoxicity
and and even I think over the years from
what researchers have done this is not
me saying I think uh Dr Carol and
everyone who works on TV will will
attest to the fact that and I'm talking
from what they have done from their work
that bedak villain is seen as something
safer and you know and the fact that it
is not really uh I don't think these
kind of medicines should exist anymore
where they just pack off your ears or
they pack off your kidneys and things
like that and and and what I was I was
barely 23 24 years old I keep I keep
saying and emphasizing on my age uh only
because of the fact that it's a it's a
young girl and we were young people who
had to go through these kind of
experiences which was I feel I felt at
least the hearing loss bit could have
been completely avoided had we seen
better drugs available for or better
treatments whether it is Diagnostics or
even whether it is better medicines
um and I say that before you know before
I hand it over to you John I say that
because uh I actually got this
realization even more when I saw what
happened with kovid so in the two years
when I when we saw the covet crisis
unfold I was in the UK and I was
pursuing a masters at the University of
Oxford where I had received a full
scholarship to go and study there and I
was seeing the covet crisis unfold and I
saw the kind of treatments that were
coming up every other day and every
other every other week I would see an
announcement of a drug of a vaccine or
something that's just coming up but and
and then but then I would think that
everybody were talking about oh my God
we have to isolate ourselves we are
feeling so terrible we are feeling so
lonely and I would think that this is
not something new I've gone through all
of this already yeah
that was that that sort of uh the
dissonance was very stuck when I saw
especially covet made me realize that
the difference
yeah yeah I mean I think it says a lot
like the reason we're in this mess is
because between 1940 and 1965 in those
25 years we developed eight classes of
drugs that can treat tuberculosis and
then between 1965 and 2013 we developed
none
and you know now we have badakaline
um we have some promising new Therapies
in the pipeline
um but that 40 years where we basically
completely ignored tuberculosis as a
global Health Community was catastrophic
and
um and and I think it's really important
to know that that's a catastrophe that
real people feel in their real lives
I want to turn to you I know you had a
lot of challenges around Diagnostics and
you know one of the reasons so we've
been talking about the dacqueline and
Johnson and Johnson's choice to continue
to apply their secondary patent
um even though access has expanded I
know you're from South Africa where
um just today actually wonderfully
another big victory for TV TV Fighters
just today it was announced that um the
South African government is going to be
investigating uh jnj's uh attempts to
continue to enforce their secondary
patents in in South Africa and keep
those prices artificially High even as
much of the world is seeing lower cost
generics thanks to the work that y'all
have done
um so I wanna I I wondered if you could
talk about that indeed
I wondered if you could talk about that
um and how you feel about that news
today
um and then and then talk a little bit
about your your journey and your journey
to diagnosis because I know it was
difficult and I know in a world with
Gene expert machines it might have been
very different
yes thank you John so I think it's good
news because South Africa is the only
country that was actually
um getting a bit of Colleen from
Transcendence and it's a much higher
price compared to any other country so
it was unfair for people actually living
with the disease and as activists we
were angry because why that was that was
the question but um yes going back to my
story
uh so it took a while for me to get the
correct TB diagnostic uh because at the
time I was a student a first day student
at University I was 19 years old I saw
that I was not well I didn't have a
common TP symptoms or the obvious typist
symptoms just that I got typed easily
and I had struggle like climbing the
stairs so I went to the doctor and then
the doctor checked for all common
diseases including HIV they all came
back negative but then he saw that I was
not told and at this point I was lost
like I was I was very thin he said that
I must do a TB test at a local Clinic
here in Cape Town so private doctors do
not check for TV they refer you to the
cleaning public clinic so I went to the
clinic very sick struggling to work
strongly to break like shortness of
breath and then uh got tested for TV and
told them why I was there quotation for
TV I had to wait at this time for three
weeks to get the results but then I was
only given like pain medication although
I was not in pain which didn't make
sense but they had to do something I
assume
um so I went back to the green to get
the results after two to three weeks and
then the results show that it was
negative meaning that I do not have
taping but because they saw the
situation I was in I mean I was like my
lowest weight 32 kg that's what it is in
pounds in America Canada 70.
it's very thin so they said I must do a
Chex X-ray and then I go to another
clinic to get a checks X-ray and then I
was diagnosed through the checks X-ray
and then I was started on this first
line TV drugs there's no normality I
call it normal TB very big topless they
were easy to take but then I was not
getting better I was getting worse
so I went back to the clinic got tested
again and this time around the results
came back they told me that a
multi-track resistant we also known as
MTR TV and then I needed to be
hospitalized because I was very
infectious and then they gave me like
this cocktail of drugs like 25 tablets
and then there was also an injection
that Nandita talked about and then there
was no explanation we're just giving the
trapsody off but then uh I don't know
how but I woke up in hospital at
Brooklyn Trust hospital here in Cape
Town and uh with this you know taking
this drug I thought it was a joke
because it's different drugs different
colors different sizes it's not like
you're gonna take them and then it's
gonna be fine it doesn't work like that
you take them
they come out you vomit and then after
months doing that almost every day with
no the injections it's very very painful
it's been described as if you have been
injected by lava that that hot thing
that yeah so it's very um imagine
getting that injection every day the
electron already get that for six months
it was very painful but then I woke up
as similar to Nandita but my story is
that I woke up and then I could not hear
anything you know went to the bathroom
when you wake up and then there was no
sound of running water no sound of the
toilet flushing nothing was quiet the
nurse came she was talking I know this
because her lips were moving but I could
not make up what she was saying she also
just took a pen and paper and just write
down everything that I must go to you oh
you know or your department look at my
ears tested I did the test I could hear
some sounds I could not hear some sounds
and then it was the most awkward thing
because on my folder no one was talking
to me because I could not hear them but
they're all deaf and capital letters in
a red pen then they wrote that I must go
to the doctor the doctor explained you
know what was happening in writing and
then I had to do the speaking and then I
could not even hear myself which is what
the most confusing thing it felt like a
dream because this can't be real no one
told me that I should expect you know
being deaf and then they explained
everything they were very sorry there's
nothing that they can do this and that
and then they told me I pre-exed their
TV then I needed to be tested again for
some reason no doctors maybe doctors in
this room will explain all of that and
then I got tested again then they saw
something unusual in my lungs they
assumed cancer they assumed tumor but
depressed those questions
that was building in my lungs caused by
TV treatment or TB and then I did the
surgery where I broke a lung and the
collapse rate
said sorry again then I was discharged
you know getting better and then I was
trying to start to go home to finish my
pre-ester TV drugs but uh after nine
months or so
they told me like 20 of travel surviving
and that they pre-ext their activity
tracks have stopped working and now
these I have full-blown xdr TV and I was
given an option because at that clinic
there was an msf Doctor Who was that
professional history explained fully
each track that I'll be taking and then
they told me about this other drug that
they were willing to try it it was my
choice whether I want to take the drug
or not so they gave me a choice I used I
take the drug and hope for a miracle
that's what you said or I don't take the
drug and then it just passed away
because I was also advised to say press
you know to prepare my soul long story
it's very very long but anyway
after intervention from msf and uh you
know my willingness to live I was
finally killed after three years in
eight months and sadly enough as Nita
was also deaf so I didn't mean that I
could not go back to universities I was
the first student
so
um I don't know I was Googling how to
get your hearing back not curious and
then I saw all those things these things
online and then I come across Cochlear
implants yes we are fortunate enough to
get Cochlear implants but they are very
very expensive 40 000 US Dollars and
that's about close to a million it's
expensive in any currency but what I
wish could have happened is that when I
knew they knew that I was sick like I
knew that I was sick so I went to seek
help I wish that there was this test
like it is now to expect test to get
tested and then they know exactly what
is wrong with you they need this extra
does says XTR because I was only told
later that there is a chance that I
actually had XBR from the start all of
that could have been prevented my
hearing loss my vomiting year today all
of that suffering for three years in
English could have been prevented if
there was no this mission that is not
available now the actual test that
everyone can have access to it yeah and
I I I I read that you took between
twenty thousand and thirty thousand
pills during your treatment
it's a lot it's so beyond oh God it's um
it's it's unbelievable
um and then you know uh but but the
story might have been very different if
you'd had access to a gene expert
machine because we've we've talked about
this in our community but about half of
the
um tests that go through smear
microscopy
um that have tuberculosis don't detect
it and so that's why fumezo probably was
told that she was negative for
tuberculosis wasn't anything that anyone
did wrong it's just that the test isn't
very good because it's 130 years old
um and if you'd had that Gene expert
test immediately
um you're right you would have been
spared so much of that and that's why we
feel so strongly about fighting for
bigger better access to these Gene
expert tests they're amazing tests but
um over charging for them is is causing
just a tremendous amount of real harm
yeah so it never makes sense to me is
this solution make this solution and
then you make the solution not easily
accessible to actually people who need
them the most then what is the point of
doing that same as with pericolin same
as you can expect why make something and
make it make it to help but then it's
not exactly people actually need it the
most so that they can have a quality
life you know continue with their lives
and just be as normal as possible that's
right because normally
that's exactly right so I I just want
people to understand that that's the
core disagreement we have with danaher
and with cepheid is that we we believe
that it is not useful to make a tool
that that the people who need it most
can't use and we believe what Dr Peter
mugenie said uh 25 years ago about HIV
treatment where the drugs the drugs are
where the disease is not and where is
the disease the disease is where the
drugs are not and as long as the tests
and the treatments are where the disease
is not for tuberculosis we are
fundamentally failing at the point of
medical care which is not to invent
life-saving treatments but to invent and
distribute life-saving treatments so I
want to um turn now uh to Dr anamesh
Sinha who works at msf and I want to ask
you rock
why
do we call TB a disease of poverty why
do we talk so much I don't love this
phrase because I don't think most people
know what it means but why do we talk so
much about the social determinants of
Health when it comes to tuberculosis
tuberculosis has classically been
associated with poverty or with a
deteriorated socio-economic conditions
so after a war uh after we go through a
tough time or in places where people are
still living in poverty you see
increased incidence or increased number
of people suffering from tuberculosis as
and when the status of the community
improves uh and the living conditions
get better nutrition get better immunity
gets better the incidence of
tuberculosis gradually reduces as we
have seen happening in the U.S because
previously U.S also had tuberculosis but
it gradually declined as the
socio-economic conditions improve
however a vast majority of the cases in
the world today still happen in low and
middle income countries that India
accounts for around 3 million of the
around 10 million cases that happen
every year yeah 3 million is a huge
number
and this
is
will take time to improve however it
does not mean that people who are
suffering today deserve to die or
deserve not to get diagnosed or treated
correctly so even though there is
poverty even though there is incidence
of tuberculosis High we still have to
diagnose those people correctly and we
still have to put those people on the
correct treatment
right and to the point of diagnosing
those people correctly I wonder if you
could talk about the role that the gene
expert machine and uh cepheid's tests
play in that process and what the
difference is between having a gene
expert diagnosis and or a diagnostic
experience more like the one that fumesa
had where it's weeks and weeks between
the test and and the results and often
takes you know often people go
undiagnosed entirely yeah
of the 10 million people who are
estimated to have TB every year
only a few people get diagnosed with the
correct tests that they need a vast
majority still get a microscopy as the
Baseline test microscopy misses out half
the people who have tuberculosis
and top of that even if microscopy tells
you that you have tuberculosis it
doesn't tell you whether you have drug
resistant or drug sensitive tuberculosis
so somebody might come up with a
diagnosis that oh I've got tuberculosis
based on microscopy and then you have
started on a first line treatment which
is basically a drug sensitive
tuberculosis treatment and by the time
you start to realize that this treatment
is not working for me it's it's already
quite late because you start becoming
resistant to all the drugs you have been
taking so there is more and more
development of resistance as as we have
seen uh in in many cases
what is actually needed as fuiza was
also saying what is actually needed is a
test which at the beginning can tell you
whether you have tuberculosis and
whether the drugs that you use to treat
tuberculosis with will work or not in
that particular case Gene expert is a
test which tells you whether you have
tuberculosis as well as tells you
whether it is resistant or not and then
the the second advantage of Gene expert
and similar test is that it tells you
in a very short amount of time within
two hours it will tell you whether you
have TB or not if classically if you
have to detect drug resistance it can
take months you have to take a sample
you have to culture the sample the
bacteria will grow then you'll have to
test different drugs on the bacteria to
say to see which ones will work which
ones won't work that takes months and by
that time in many cases it's already too
late patients have have patients are
already suffering with tuberculosis and
then you put them on toxic drugs which
are not working for them
so Gene experts solves a lot of these
problems but it's it's it's it's not
accessible to everybody and that's
that's an issue
yeah so I wonder if you could talk about
that that lack of accessibility like how
often people are unable to access Gene
expert uh tests because of cost and
whether cost is because I think one of
cepheid's arguments is that cost is not
really the I mean we don't know what
suffield's arguments are because they've
never spoken publicly about this which
is infuriating
um and I should say danaher and cepheid
because danaher is the gigantic company
that owns cepheid
um but I wonder if you can talk about
um you know one of the arguments that
that they have used in the past is that
cost is not the main barrier to access
and I wonder how you would respond to
that
I don't think that is particularly
correct because if barrier if if cost
was not a warrior I think most countries
would be rolling it out quickly because
first of all it solves the issues with
the practitioners who have to diagnose
people and secondly it helps the
patients so there is no reason why a
doctor who's supposed to care for a
patient would avoid using a test which
is better for the patient it's just
because they don't have that test
available within the systems and the
reason why it's not available within the
systems is because most of these
countries where the burden of
tuberculosis is are low and middle
income countries and they don't have the
resources to buy so many tests if India
had to buy for the 3 million people who
are estimated to have tuberculosis you
have to test many times more people to
be diagnosed to be able to diagnose
those three million and to able to
procure those number of tests would
require a huge budget with the cost of
the cartridge that that currently is
being sold at so unless the costs come
down it is impossible for many low and
middle income countries to be able to
roll out these tests at a scale which
will be able to pick up most of the
cases who go missing every year right
right we've also gotten a question in
chat that I wanted to ask you about
Diagnostics because many people
especially in in the US are are familiar
with tuberculosis testing only through
the lens of skin testing so can you talk
a little bit about skin testing and the
upsides and downsides of skin testing
and why gene expert tests are um are are
are better even if they're more
expensive and I should say they're
currently more expensive they don't have
to be expensive that's not like cost
Effectiveness is a moving Target based
on how much dynahurst decides to charge
yeah uh skin tests are tests for TV
infection which basically tell you
whether or not you've been exposed to
the bacteria it won't tell you whether
you have active tuberculosis disease
whether you're suffering whether you are
ill with the disease or not so a skin
test might tell you that oh at some
point in the past you were exposed to
the bacteria but that does not
necessarily mean that you you have the
disease or that you require a particular
kind of treatment Gene expert is the one
which will tell you whether you require
whether you have active disease and
whether you require treatment skin tests
might be beneficial in certain
circumstances however it is not the test
of choice for the vast majority of
people who suffer from tuberculosis
right
um and and because a lot of people have
been exposed to TB you know something
like two and a half or three billion
people might test positive on a skin
test
that's correct yeah
um okay Dr mitnick can I can I move
toward toward toward you
Kai
Dr mitnick and I are our our friends we
were friends before this
um so you've been you've been in this
world for a long time
um and I wonder if we can start by you
telling a story or two about changes
that you have witnessed in the treatment
of people with drug resistant TB after
the introduction of badakaline and and
the newer drugs
thank you and um thanks so much for
organizing this I'm thrilled to be in
the company of the two of the recent uh
winners of the times 100 next I guess
one one prior winner yeah
just got just got awarded uh just got
acknowledged as the time 100 next among
the time 100 next most influential
people although I would argue that they
should be on the time 100 Now list of
most most influential people exactly
well there's more more to come more to
come you are still young y'all
so
um John I I think it's a super important
question and we already heard from who
Mesa just how transformative the
treatment was she was
um
had been poorly treated
um you know late late diagnosis because
of the poor tests that were available at
the time and after close to three years
of treatment with other regimens even at
that point but Jacqueline was able to be
part of a regimen that cured her and
knew John have observed it in your
friend Henry as well many have called it
a Lazarus effect kind of like what
people were saying about antiretroviral
therapy when it first became available
for HIV that on the individual level the
results are nothing short of
transformative
and then on the population level on the
kind of whole practice level the same is
true but Jacqueline is now the linchpin
of every single treatment for multi-drug
resistant TB that's true for adults
that's true for children that's true for
pregnant people that's true for people
who are living with HIV it doesn't
matter it's the it is the foundation of
every single one of the multi-drug
regimens and so the cost of that drug is
so important to the half a million new
people that half a million people who
get newly
um sorry to get drug resistant TV newly
each year and I want to emphasize that
we fail to treat so many of those people
each year we treat something on the
order of 200 000 or less of those 500
000 maybe new cases but there's this
backlog there's there are these million
or a million and a half people
accumulating with drug resistant TB over
the years because they haven't been
treated and you can actually live with
TB and drug resistant TB for a long time
so badapolin is really part of a whole
treatment transformation that's kind of
analogous to what happened with
treatment for run-of-the-mill TB in the
1970s when we got these very exciting
now old drugs called piracinamide and
Rifampin where treatment was shortened
from 18 months to six months and that's
exactly what we're seeing because of
badaqueline and some other components
now and so more people can get treatment
for less money less Health System
investment less Health System investment
in the toxic
were both describing who Mesa thought
she took her pills okay that was that
was done for that but no it wasn't
because then she vomited and that takes
a lot of support for people to to make
it through that care but if you have
something that's more tolerable like the
badapolin-based regimens there's so much
more promise
yeah and for for those who don't know Dr
mitnick was a really important part of
the research in Peru in the early 1990s
proving that mdrtb could be treated
effectively in low and middle income
countries which uh really transformed
the way that that we treat mdrtb I mean
Dr mitnick once described to me the
previous who regulation before the
um before the evidence came in that it
was possible to treat mdrtb effectively
in poor countries she described it to me
the the that the who's regimen was
essentially let someone sit on the side
of the road until they die
and um
and and now you know more people are
able to access treatment I think it's
really important to understand that
progress is possible and that we've seen
progress
um but progress is harder than it needs
to be uh and as fumeza said earlier like
one of the frustrations here is just
like well why did you why do you develop
these Technologies if you don't want
people to use them like what is the what
is the surely the motivation can't be
only money like nobody nobody when they
were like nine years old thought when I
grow up I want to be a a an executive at
a pharmaceutical company so that I can
minimize the number of people who can
access my life-saving treatments
um and I and I don't think people think
that way right like I gen I I genuinely
think most people don't think that
they're they're bad you know I genuinely
think that like these are people who are
trying to make the world better
um and I just you know I just I just
think sometimes people need polite but
insistent reminders
um of of the best way that the best ways
to do that sometimes don't involve
maximizing profit
um or at least don't involve maximizing
short-term profit because I would argue
that danaher would actually make a lot
of money if they were selling 45 million
TB tests to India every year and the
only way they can do that is by lowering
their prices
um Dr mitnick I also wanted to ask you
um what you would say to these
pharmaceutical companies um how would
you talk to them in talking about
um access to drugs like but alkaline and
the absolute importance of those
life-saving diagnostic tools like like
the gene expert machine
yeah
um I I think you you were starting to go
down that path John and I guess what I
would say is there are so many other
direct and indirect benefits of working
in this space
um despite the protestations of these of
these companies uh to the contrary they
get really good PR for doing good work
for people who are most in need they can
have very motivated employees and good
retention which costs them less as you
said these are not inherently bad people
people don't go work in industry in
Pharma or in biotech because they want
to restrict access that's that's not why
they do it they do it for the thrill of
Discovery and discovery that will help
people so if it doesn't help people and
they get and there are campaigns like
this that's got to be super demoralizing
but if they're and they can really
capitalize on on the benefit of this
work internally as well they also these
companies get exposure to emerging
markets for other products by getting
their name out there Johnson and Johnson
as you've made so clear John is it's a
household name in the U.S and they have
products all over the world so you know
bedackle and helps bring name
recognition to them and allows them to
sell more products on which people's
lives do not depend
and then I I would also argue that they
already get some of these benefits the
Public Funding that substantially
reduces their investment in r d we know
that estimates of the investment made in
badapolin are that somewhere between 1.6
and 5 times the investment that Johnson
and Johnson made in budakolan was made
by tax dollars from people around the
world largely in the U.S and that
include that includes investments in
research and development that includes
investment in Early Access that includes
paying for a phase three trial that
Johnson and Johnson should have paid for
they've also gotten a waiver from excuse
me a voucher from the Food and Drug
Administration that they can use for
another drug to get an accelerated
review so there are all kinds of
benefits is what I would say to them
they don't have to rely on unlimited
profits
yeah Matt just said this is crazy to me
I had no idea how egregious this was
good that's um that's why we're doing
this Matt is to call attention to how
egregious this is and to try to help um
help each other uh work together to help
these companies understand that they can
make better choices and and that they
can and those choices can still be good
for business as Dr mitnick just pointed
out I do want to say
um you know if you
there will be info about this after we
um after we finish the live stream like
in in in the comments and and in the
video info but um if you're as inspired
by this conversation as I am please
reach out to danaher tag them on social
media reach out to them via phone
although they did shut down their
public-facing phone line yesterday and
it's still not back up
um but there is another number that you
can call and leave a message
um they're be polite of course
um the person who's answering the phone
is not uh the person who's making the
decision but um but I think it's
important for them to know that we're
paying attention and we're going to keep
paying attention and this is not a
two-day campaign you know this is
something that
um msf and andita and fumesa and Dr
mitnik and and Dr Sin I've been working
on for for years and years and years and
so this isn't day two of two this is uh
you know for them day
1388 of however many days it takes and
um I think it's really important for
danaher to know that to know that like
this isn't going away this isn't a storm
that's going to blow over and so please
reach out to them on email tag them on
social media
um
it works they don't like it we know they
don't like it because there are a lot of
danaher and cepheid employees um who are
in my DMs uh telling me that they don't
like it and also telling me exactly what
Dr mitnick said which is that they
didn't get into this business
um and and dream about doing this work
in order to deny patients access and so
I think the the internal pressure is
really key as well if you work at
danaher or cepheid or know someone who
does uh just know that that internal
pressure is also mounting and working
um so uh I want to open it up for
questions now to our lovely Community
um you can flood the chat with questions
because I'm really good at reading them
reading the questions fast after 17
years of doing live streams so and then
I will ask the questions
um
uh but yeah do do try to be
um do try to be respectful I don't I
like having DMS that are only about
tuberculosis actually it's great um it's
very clarifying so no problems there
um we have not heard anything unless
Something's Happened in the last hour we
haven't heard anything from our friends
at danaher and cepheid um which tends to
be their usual calm strategy but we will
eventually because we'll just keep
escalating
um
so yeah so please leave your questions
and comments and we'll go from there
um I'm so grateful to be able to talk
with all of y'all and um yeah thank you
uh Elian asks a great question that I
don't know if we have an answer for is
do we know how much of the the
percentage of the development of Gene
expert came from Public Funding I don't
know if anyone wants to comment on that
we know that it was 250 million dollars
I don't know what percentage that was of
their total funding
oh look it even appears on the screen
the question goodness gracious
um John I don't know if uh others can
answer that question I can't but I can
just say generally that this is part of
the problem is a total lack of
transparency about the cost to
manufacture the individual cartridge the
costs of investment in the whole in the
whole product development and so we're
left
either doing independent studies like
the one that msf commissioned to to come
up with the cost of the cartridge as
being between 350 and four dollars
um or uh just waiting for them to say
something
right yeah John if I may add uh uh safed
received around 250 million dollars in
Public Funding to develop the uh expert
technology
yeah that's a lot of money
a lot of that a lot of that came from
the NIH a lot of that came from American
taxpayers a lot of it came from uh
taxpayers outside the U.S as well
um and you know one of the frustrations
here is that when taxpayers pay for
something like I remember once I I had
an infection behind my eye and I had to
get this very expensive antibiotic that
was twelve thousand dollars a pill and I
remember my doctor saying to me
um you know what's really frustrating
about this man is that you're paying for
this twice because we also paid for this
drug to get developed
and I think that's very true
uh Nandita and fumasia we've got a
couple questions for you
um or a lot of questions for you
actually I bragged about how I was
really good at reading questions but the
questions are actually coming in faster
than I'm used to I will say if the 1148
people watching right now
um were to all reach out to Dan her at
the same time it'd be a be a good
morning to push them to respond in some
ways
um there is a list of danaher's
investors that nerdfighteria has
researched we're reaching out to some of
those investors you can find out more at
our our Discord at nerdfighteria.com
um
so Nandita and and fumesa can you talk
about some of the experiences of um of
other patients you've known including um
uh peep friends friends you've lost I
think it's really important because you
know your your stories are are so
inspiring
um but I think it's really important
also not to forget the people who joined
us in this fight and aren't here to uh
celebrate Johnson and Johnson's
expansion of badakaline access
um and um and have passed away I I don't
know if that's something that you'd be
comfortable talking about but I think
that's something that I um I try to I
try to talk about in each each of these
things that I do because I just think
it's really important to remember those
people and remember their contributions
either of you can unmute
if you want or if you don't want to
answer that question just stay on mute
no it's when I think I can go so yes
because I was in Muslim Hospital
for almost a year so obviously you sort
of like make relationships and you get
close to people and there's the people
who were close to me that I lost who
could have been saved if they were like
better drugs at that time that I had TB
but then another problem is that it's
not only the drugs or the diagnostic
there's also stigma that is still a huge
problem when it comes to TP I mean I've
met people who don't want to disclose
that they're a TV because it's for some
reason it's been you know set to
Performance Disease by the media it's
almost associated with being debt and
all of those bad things but then it sort
of like also stop people to actually
talk about it make it as normal as
possible there are very few people who
actually stand up and talk about having
table or talk about their experiences
and that is the problem because we need
to break down the stigma that people can
be able to seek the care that they need
to be able to to get the help I think it
is easily and also as comfortable as
possible then yes we need to break down
the stigma and to translate Johnson is
safe we have many problems and medicaps
in TB we can't we can't also be of
worrying about to be making medication
that is available and also the
technology that is already available we
need to have one appropriate at a time
and I will make it very difficult for us
is to be survivors and actual people
actually care about TV
yeah Nandita can you talk a little bit
about stigma as well I mean this is
something that I've seen over and over
again that
um that this the stigma is just so uh
complex and profound that it really does
seem to limit the ability of
um people to live even at years after
they survive TB
so yeah so TV is a stigmatized disease
and I think over the years has uh my My
Hope Is that as more and more People
Like Us come out and share our
experiences it will give a lot more
other people the courage to come out and
also feel better about the fact that
there are people there there is someone
that they can look up to during their
treatment but TB is a stigmatized
disease because a it's it's contagious
but not all forms of the disease are
contagious so I remember that when I got
TB
though it was not a contagious form of
the disease because I had it in the
intestine still I was told that please
don't talk about this to anyone or
please don't share about this to anyone
because of the fact that TV is known to
be contagious so everybody will
everybody if there's a possibility that
people could start shunning you or
people could get distant from you and I
don't and it's not about blaming the
other person because just because the
knowledge about TV is just so poor among
the public that any person let's say
tomorrow an acquaintance knows that I'm
I'm having TB the natural the natural
reaction would be that a person a person
would get scared that oh okay am I will
I also contract the disease but a but
even though it was not contagious for me
I was still told that you don't you be a
bit quiet about it so I would often tell
people that I was having intestinal
infection so it was a very vague way to
tell it that I would say it was
intestinal infection I would never tell
the word of the disease very openly to
anyone apart from a few few close
members of the family and and I I think
this is not just uh you know not my
experience alone but it is an experience
with a lot of other people as well
globally I say uh because uh because of
the fact that uh people don't know that
TB is not contagious after a couple of
months if you take your treatment for
the first few months or weeks very well
and you're adhere to the treatment you
you do become non-infectious so these
kind of Minor Details about the disease
need to be out there more openly so that
so that the so that the other person can
live in a sort of less fear about it and
the person will feel more uh more loved
and approachable so I think that those
those are one of the reasons I think and
and also because of the fact that again
because this the knowledge about the
disease continues to be so poor so there
is a possibility that that for example
people don't know whether let's say
whether you can have a partner during
your sickness during whether you can
date someone whether you can uh you know
whether you can have a normal life all
of that is possible that's the point you
can do everything but you should but
adhere to the treatment and follow the
treatment and then you know have more
importantly have a very good nutritious
diet and then you will be fine so these
kind of uh you know important positive
messaging as well as important points
that need to be out there so that people
know exactly they don't live in constant
fear so I think that is where I feel the
the problem lies right now yeah
yeah no I think that's so true I what
you were just saying reminded me of a
memoir I read by a woman who lived in
the she's still alive actually but but
she contracted TB in the early mid 20th
century
um when she was a child and uh lived in
the United States in in sanitariums um
while she was trying to recover before
eventually getting access to
streptomycin and and having her life
saved and uh she wrote that when she
finally was able to go home she had
forgotten what it was like to be touched
with love
um that she you know like her her you
know with her nurses and everything
maybe they would turn her over or they
would pick her up but to to just be held
to just have her face stroked that was
something that she had not that hadn't
happened in so long since she was a
little kid because people were afraid of
her
and that's so heartbreaking and to your
point it's so unnecessary because we
know that once people have been um in
treatment for a few weeks they're no
longer infectious
um they're actually like much less of a
threat to me or to you than than you
know just walking or walking around or
being on a crowded bus would be
um so
I uh I want to we only have 10 minutes
left and I have to go upstairs because I
did not plan my battery life very well
um so as I walk upstairs to plug my
computer in
um this is a super professional live
stream uh I want to uh offer each of you
the chance to kind of give us some some
closing remarks if there's if there's
something that that you want to say that
you haven't said something that you want
to tell people
about your experience or about what um
you think we can accomplish together and
maybe I'll start with Dr mitnik
[Music]
thanks John
um and thanks nandy Temple Mesa for for
those comments about stigma I guess
maybe I would
um wrap up with two things one unplanned
about on the stigma front
um
I generally the
um response to destigmatizing is to tell
the people with the stigmatized
condition to disclose that somehow
that's supposed to magically
destigmatize the condition and it puts
more burden on the person who's already
unwell in the case of say TB and I I
just want to highlight what you guys
were all saying that if diagnosis is
rapid if treatment is rapid people
become non-infectious pretty much as
soon as the treatment starts all of
these are ways to destigmatize the
disease and and for communities to
understand that the best thing they can
do is support people to get Prompt Care
and help them through care so that would
be one remark on this issue around the
profits from these companies that are
making products that are easy essential
to the lives of people with TB are
affected by TB I would say that
unlimited profiteering kills and that we
have to have limits on profits on
life-saving treatment and it's it's not
either or there is still room for profit
to drive Innovation but there can still
be limits on it and in the same vein no
more of this double dipping no more you
get to get public funds to develop
something and then you get to profit uh
endlessly from it
I think you're on mute John
oh okay great thank you Carol I was
going to turn over to Dr Sinnoh
uh yeah I think uh what Nandita and
fumeza have brought out is uh is what
many people go through every year and
for the last many years
what could be done is the uh the U.S
Diagnostics company sephid and its
parent company then uh should drop the
price of Gene expert cartridge to Dollar
five for all diseases including
tuberculosis which would improve the
diagnosis of tuberculosis find those
people who are missing and uh be able to
start them on the correct treatment
early so that they could have a better
life and and a better success of
treatment
yeah yeah
so when it comes to testing as I said
it's not easy to just wake up and go to
the clinic so yes we need to recall the
stigma but there's also another thing
called Universal testing for TV also
known as Tutt this provides like annual
activity
testing for people living with HIV as
well as testing of all contacts of
people with TB and also people who have
been previously treated with TB like
myself in Nandita so in a South Africa
and Cape Town those South African
contacts and TV services should also be
available close to to where people live
because you find that people because of
stigma instead of going to the clinic
that is close to them they are
vertically they go to the other thing to
avoid being seen by the community that
they live in so yes it should be as I
said UDP cell testing for TV and also it
should be available to where people live
like where they they believe is thank
you yeah no I think that's so important
that
um if you ask people it's it's so much
to say to say like you the only way you
can get treatment and Diagnostics is to
pay for transportation to walk long
distances uh that just makes it
inaccessible to so many people so I
think that's such an important point
Thank you and Nandita
so I think uh everyone Dr
Nick I think they've made very important
points but I wanted to tell a word on
the patent proposition that we won
um was that we had our share of Skeptics
along the journey we had people you know
maybe off the Record question us as to
you know what was what was our
motivations behind doing something like
this because we were not going to get
bed aquiline in any way both of us we
had completed our treatment by then and
we will we were leading perfectly okay
lives but why what were our motivations
we got questions like these as well but
uh we we also were asked okay are you
against Innovation you know why are you
are you against Innovation do you have
any idea about how the economics Works
behind this and I think uh all of that
so sort of questions have been put late
to rest hopefully with what has happened
and hope I hope that today's discussion
sort of throws a light on all of these
questions
is that a I think neither of us none of
the pandas but I can speak for myself at
least is that I'm certainly not against
any form of innovation I want what we
want is that the Innovation actually
reaches more people that's all that was
the main motive behind this it is not
about us uh you know not understanding
the economics I think that's that that's
the most frivolous comment to say
because both of us we are Highly
Educated people we know what we were
talking about but things like this I
think I hope they uh I hope the message
goes out loud and clear is that what we
want is that essentially is that it
reaches the people it has to reach I
think science has to benefit everyone
and not just not just some people
yeah I mean Innovation you're in favor
of innovation I would argue you're
strongly in favor of innovation because
Innovation is not just innovating the
number of drug compounds or tests that
we know how to do Innovation is also
innovating how we get those tests and
compounds to the places they're needed
how we produce them at scale how we you
know all of those questions of
innovation right like we we talk a lot
about Alexander Fleming discovering
penicillin in 1928 but it wasn't uh
Alexander Fleming discovering penicillin
in 1928 actually wasn't the big
innovation the big innovation was in the
early 1940s when large groups of
scientists working together figured out
how to make penicillin more than a drop
at a time so that we could actually get
it into people to have to help them and
um and to me that's the work that that
you're doing uh which is I think the
much more Innovative and important work
uh so I'm I'm just so grateful to both
of you uh to fumeza and Nandita our
newest time 100 next fellow
um but but uh just just two people who
who I admire so much and um and I know
we'll be leading continuing to lead the
charge
um toward breaking down that stigma
toward increasing access to Diagnostics
and and drugs
um starting uh just in just a few days
at the U.N General Assembly
um and the high level meeting on
tuberculosis so thank you both so much
Dr mitnick uh for all of your great work
for leading the way for leading me uh on
this path um I'm so grateful to you and
to Dr anamesh Sinha who's work uh has
saved countless lives um we are so
grateful to you the last thing I want to
say is that we're really grateful to the
people who are here
um who are in this um audience with us
uh including sriha who just called the
cepheid phone number and got to talk to
a person within just two minutes so good
job
um she pressed one two times and got to
talk to a human being so thank you for
doing that
um thank you for continuing to keep up
the pressure on on danaher thank you for
continuing to monitor Johnson and
Johnson and and pressure them to expand
access to badakaline and um thank you
for being part of this community with us
uh what what we're accomplishing
together is another reminder that you
human beings do very little alone almost
everything that we do we do together and
what we can do together is so much more
than what we understand sometimes I know
it's easy to feel powerless I know it's
easy to feel despair I know that the
problems we Face together are
overwhelming and at times feel utterly
intractable it's easy to feel hopeless
in the face of them but I still think
that hope is is the correct response to
the miracle of human consciousness I
still think that we can make a better
world together and that starts uh that
starts every day every day we have that
opportunity to work together for a
better world I'm so grateful that y'all
are working with us and I'm so grateful
to be able to work with the four people
who joined us on our panel today so
thank you very much and as we say in my
hometown don't forget to be awesome